hello everyone how you guys doing hope
you guys are having a wonderful day and
today we are here with another video
this video will be on testing the
crystal keys and seeing if they are
profitable through opening up I believe
it's just the crystal chest
it is indeed called the crystal chest so
there is a way that I could calculate
what your average return on value would
be for each crystal key however I'm
going to just test it in theory so we're
gonna go ahead by 500 cuz we're gonna go
ahead by 500 crystal keys at the grand
exchange right now so I will meet you
guys there here in a second there we are
finished up buying most everything that
we need so went ahead it got a bunch of
two thefts and a lot of loops I bought
as many crystal keys as I could have
with at the time being while I was
buying these so I'm gonna go ahead put
these all together find the average
price of the crystal key and we're gonna
go ahead and open up 500 of these chests
finish that up so those are the last
three keys and now up to 500 crystal
keys took me about five minutes to go
ahead and make 350 of them so not too
bad at all but I'm gonna go ahead and
figure out what the total cost is right
now so as you guys can see we got a 135
right there for 3.45 milk that would
mean I bought about 365 crystal keys in
the form of loop and tooth half so I'm
gonna go ahead and add that up right now
so as you guys can see I was buying them
I guess they're down here more so I'll
go ahead and show that real quick so 8.3
right down there and 8.3 as you guys can
see there so eight three one two plus
the price that I was buying 2017 oh one
one and then we're going to take that
number and divide it or multiply it
times 365 and that will give us how much
we spent on the keys and then we have to
add on what we spent for the 350 right
there so and then with that all added up
we ended up spending 12.7 mm oh stop I'm
gonna go ahead open those all up right
now for you guys and then we will see
what we end up getting from that alright
so one thing that we were going to need
to do before we are able to do all these
keys is go ahead and switch our house to
taverley for 5000 coins and now I can
use all my house tabs there I'll be
banking using the ring of duelling and
then teleporting using a house tab so
that is the plan for now I think I'm
gonna start off with like 12 keys per
inventory and we'll see how that goes
but I'm gonna go ahead and do all 500
now now to show you guys how I'm going
to
in average inventories so the amount of
keys I have may not be the most
beneficial but I'd rather take one or
two too many than one or two too less so
basically also I'm gonna do start is so
basically all I'm going to do is start
at the castle Wars then I go into
teleport using my taverley home teleport
and then come over here to this clothes
chest and also I'm going to need to do
is use a crystal key on it as you can
see they're only returned one dragon
stone so not a very good margin there as
dragon stones currently are 17k and
crystal keys are 26 so I lost 9k on that
chest however for the most part you
should be able to get better loot than
that as you can see they're definitely
not making my money back with the lutes
that we've gotten this far but I mean
the problem is is that I'm hitting some
of the most common ones the rare ones
like that room plate skirt is really
what makes the money for you so I'm
gonna go ahead and just open up the rest
of this inventory then we'll see how
much I was able to make back at the bank
going to quickly go ahead and show you
guys what this inventory cost me to do
so as you guys can see here the problem
with this is I only paid about 25.3
Caper crystal key which means this
entire inventory was actually more
around like 300 and 3k rather than 317
so keep that in mind so 303 was what we
averaged on that one and now I'm gonna
go ahead and put in all the stuff that
we have in our inventory from the loot
and as you guys can see there judging by
the OS buddy price we actually lost 10k
on that however with the amount of like
however with the amount of non lucky
drops we got such as a lot of just
regular dragon stones and a lot of
dragon stone and spinach we don't plan
to lose on each chest it's more of it's
something that you can't really compare
off of just twelve Keys that's why I'm
opening up 500 so I'm gonna go ahead and
do the rest of the 500 and we will see
where we are at all right so here we are
finally finished off all 500 of the
chests so to take a little bit of time
what's hard trying to juggle all the
runes along with the sword fish a lot of
swordfish and spinach rolls were dropped
along the way because it wasn't really
worth keeping them so this isn't going
to be everything but for the most part
this is what you would expect to keep
because it's not worth it to actually
sit here and juggle them but it took me
about 45 minutes or so to do them all I
was averaging about a minute a trip and
give or take a few minutes it's about 45
minutes for all that I did
so we're gonna go ahead price check this
all right now so let me do this real
quick so as I was stated earlier it cost
me about twelve point seven to twelve
point eight million in here real quick
so I'm just gonna kind of go through
real slow and just throw in some of
these because I'm a little nervous
myself so nine point three there I think
we definitely made profit then with all
these ruin ORS or in bars we're up to
ten point nine so I'm just gonna dump
everything in here now and that brought
me to fourteen point two to fourteen
point five I'm gonna go ahead and sell
off everything but that would be insane
that's like two mil I mean oh my god I
almost don't want to upload this video
but I will I'll let you guys see how
much I end up making once I go ahead and
sell it all off but I would say that
this was definitely a success all right
everything's buying slow I decided I
can't I can't wait any more I'm just
gonna go ahead and to sell everything
and we'll see how much we made in total
after the sell and there it is so I went
ahead and got ourselves a total of
fourteen mil pretty much on the dot
which means in total we were able to
make around 1.3 mil in that in that 45
minutes I believe and there's really no
requirements other than being able to
have a house in taverley that makes it
the fastest but as far as opening the
chest that all you need is coins that's
it just going to be able buy the keys
and that is literally all you need so
hopefully this video is helpful for you
guys maybe you guys try this out
yourself the prices on these are always
a little different so I'd recommend
making your own keys rather than buying
keys but also make sure not to insta buy
because if you insta Buy you probably
won't make money on this so just keep
that in mind yeah make sure to add me
in-game hit up the Twitter in the
description if you guys enjoyed the
video make sure to leave a like comment
down below if you guys have anything you
want to tell me and yeah other than that
hope you guys have a wonderful day and
peace also one thing at the end
I know during the video I said I was
going to go ahead and calculate how much
you theoretically should be able to make
purchase based on a ton of other
people's studies but the problem I saw
is I got like I think it was like six to
eight thousand iron ore and you're only
supposed to average about four hundred
per hundred chests so I probably should
have only gotten about two thousand of
them which i think means that maybe they
recalculate based on what a dragon
stones worth and maybe up the price of
other things are up the odds of getting
better rewards so I don't really think
that there's anything that I can do
about that sand
I don't actually know what the
likelihoods of these things happening
are same thing with the room bars they
are one in three I believe I ended up
getting like 114 I should have only
gotten about 45 based on that so yeah I
mean it's just all over the place and
there's no way I can go ahead and do
that so definitely profitable though had
a lot of fun recording that's